[Musique]
mascara jardin botanique de la Réunion
officiellement lancée son application
mobile ce jeudi 14 septembre une
application déclinée en français et en
anglais
c'est une application une application
qui est téléchargeable sur les
plateformes de téléchargement media et
donc il va permettre de mettre en valeur
un petit peu le jardin botanique des
mascarins de d'explorer
le jardin d'explorer des collections qui
sont présentes au jardin donc ça va
permettre de de faire connaître
davantage ce qui se trouve ici au jardin
botanique de mascara il faut savoir que
le jardin botanique des mascara et est
un jardin qui est labellisé jardin
remarquable qui bénéficie d'une
plantation de 4000 espèces de d'arbres
indigènes et endémiques l'application
propose une balade numérique guidée en
compagnie de Lucet qui accompagne le
visiteur dans les paysages de la Réunion
un personnage inspiré de Luc et
Latchoumaya un illustre jardinier du
jardin botanique
auparavant mes parents étaient ici avant
j'étais travaillé dans comme
agricole soit à cause des ateliers et
puis au moment en 88
quand le Conseil général
comme comment
mesure sur mesure
après les indignés ils étaient faits
pour aller dans le jardinier à adapter
aux portes longtemps dans le même temps
mascara lance aussi l'explorgames un jeu
de piste sur tablette ou smartphone le
jeu s'intitule Talia le trésor de
commerçant
le but du jeu c'est une chasse au trésor
et la recherche justement d'un trésor
qui représente une planche d'herbiers
car paraît-il caché Philibert Commerson
célèbre botaniste du 18e siècle qu'il a
caché dans le jardin donc le visiteur ça
peut être des touristes ça peut être des
collégiens ça peut être la famille
réunionnaise au sens large va comme ça
être conduit d'État en étape pour
répondre à des énigmes et une fois que
l'énigme aura été résolu il passera à
l'étape suivante et à la fin arriver à
découvrir cette planche d'herbiers qui a
été
décrite par commerçant en hommage à
Jeanne barré qui rappelle a été la
première femme à faire le tour du monde
dans au 18e siècle
pour les Journées européennes du
patrimoine mascara le jardin botanique
de la réunion permettra aux visiteurs de
tester un avant-première le jeu c'est
samedi 16 et dimanche 17 septembre
[Musique]